messieurs bonjour merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france romain vidal
de commencer par vous vous en attendez
quoi de cette mobilisation de cette
mobilisation pas grand chose et nous ce
qu'on attend c'est le passé ni t on
avait demandé à ce qu'elle soit exclue
le les terrasses de nos établissements
pour pouvoir travailler plus facilement
car dans les récents il ya aussi tout ce
qui est café cafetiers donc c'est
compliqué de demander le passé ni terre
pour un café en sachant qu'on est à
l'extérieur ont plu au minimum de
risques tout ce qu'on demande surtout
c'est de pouvoir travailler et nous on
nous a clairement fait comprendre que ce
soit s'est elle pas sanitaire soit
c'était la fermeture
donc on se plie aux règles du pass
sanitaire faut bien comprendre aux
français qu'on n'a pas le choix nous si
on veut pouvoir sauver nos entreprises
et nos vies personnelles on est obligé
de travailler et on doit accepter le
pass sanitaire est ce qu'on souhaite
c'est que le mouvement même si celle ci
continue a pas de souci c'est que le
moment par contre ne dérape à et et
grève complètement nos chiffres
d'affaires et notre business comme a pu
avoir lieu les dernières manifestations
et monaco vide nicolas vidal tel regard
vous portez sur ces mobilisations on en
est aux quatrièmes samedis consécutifs
s'est dit à chaque fois plus de monde
dans la rue
exactement vous avez tout dit
effectivement je m'en suis effaré
premières observations elle parle d'une
norme mobilisation en rognant qu'un mois
d'août vous l'avez dit quatrième
week-end de participation et si
extrêmement incroyable pour des français
qui se mobilise énormément missérété 1,9
à 200000 pas pour aujourd'hui on va t'en
des chiffres bien entendu on va être
patient
rester patient mais il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus de monde
donc vraiment une première observation
c'est cet énorme énorme mobilisation
extrêmement intéressante parce que c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui sur se passe à
lithaire ya beaucoup beaucoup de
questions qui se posent et bienvenus on
sait aussi le conseil constitutionnel a
rendu sa décision son verdict et l'a
amendé la marque parce que c'est
vraiment cosmétiques et aujourd'hui les
gens sont encore aux revenus plus
nombreux dans la rue parce que
finalement je finirai par là ça pose la
question centrale de la santé publique
contre les libertés individuelles et on
voit bien que les gens sont épris de
liberté pour ceux et celles qui sont
dans la rue peut être d'autres et c'est
vraiment une question fondamentale
aujourd'hui qui se posent à nous ce qui
se posent à notre nation qui se posent à
notre société et on verra bien comment
ça va se dérouler dans les prochains
jours on a envie d'être le gouvernement
la firme ainsi des indicateurs
sanitaires continuent leur déclin
familièrement c'est le confinement qui
nous pend au nez et certains commerçants
pensent finalement que le pass à l'inter
ce le moindre mal pour les commerçants
oui oui comme je disais le le panis
terre c'était si la mesure où la
fermeture administrative
on a eu deux fermetures administratives
qui ont été très longues en a les aides
qui nous ont pas mis de survivre un tout
petit peu la première période pas grand
chose heureusement la deuxième crainte
qu'un huissier pays l'état est un peu
plus présent mais nous commerçants ça
fait des années que con qu'on survit on
entre guillemets entre les deux guerres
qui ont causé beaucoup de torts dans les
grandes villes dans les grandes
métropoles de france
ensuite on a la kobe qui nous a fermé
tout ce qu'on veut c'est pourra
travailler payer nos salariés c'est pas
rester chez nous et l'état nous fait
bien comprendre que même si on n'est pas
responsable parce que je vais peut-être
quand même que les dernières vagues ont
eu lieu quand les restes ont été fermées
donc c'est pas on n'était pas
responsable de l'augmentation
obligatoirement de l'aco vide mais il
faut à tout prix que l'on fasse
attention qui ait pas d'autres vagues
qu'on puisse reprendre une vie est la
seule solution c'est s'il faut passer
par un pass sanitaires c'est il faut
essayer qu'on l'à pic d'une façon
agréable et cordiale pour tous ce après
que facile aussi bien pour les
spectateurs que pour le client mais il
faut qu'on essaie de trouver une
solution pour sortir de cette crise
sanitaire et économique
nicolas vidal c
mobilisation on y retrouve plusieurs
débats il ya ceux qui estiment que ces
passes et liberticide discriminatoire et
puis ceux qui doutent un peu de
l'intérêt de la vaccination massive sur
ce point là pourquoi le gouvernement a
échoué mais concrètement aujourd'hui il
ya une vraie discrimination vous l'avais
dit dans une de ces manifestations et
surtout les gens pour moi pour avoir
fait quelques manifestations tant que
juriste indépendant
moi j'ai vu des gens épris de liberté
publique qui se posent la question aussi
du côté très liberticide de la
vaccination
et puis et puis il ya cette idée là de
même de notre démocratie notre
république on n'aime pas de gouvernement
et emmanuel macron impose par la
coercition et de chantage
ce n'est pas digne aujourd'hui deux
prêteurs république d'une démocratie de
république parce que finalement la
question de fond c'est à quoi sert notre
république
à quoi sert notre démocratie c'est à
dire qu'ils imaginaient en 14 18
la république n'est pas tombée alors que
la situation était tout pire offrant 14
buts et même pas comparable
et aujourd'hui on se rend compte qu'on a
un recul énorme énorme de nos libertés
individuelles qu'on soit court pour
contre le vaccin peut importe n'est
vraiment on parle de questions de
démocratie et finalement sa poche le
dire vraiment question il ya des gens
beaucoup de gens sont les manifestations
pour s'habituer à qui j'ai parlé qui
sont vraiment très très inquiet pour
leur liberté pour leur avenir et pour
l'avenir notre nation aussi et ça c'est
extrêmement inquiétant et je finirai par
là il ya quand même beaucoup de gens qui
avaient un espoir voyez-vous sur le
conseil constitué se sont dit peut-être
que le conseil constitutionnel a mende
aura finalement la loi et ben non
et bien non nous construisons
aujourd'hui avec plusieurs santé
milliers de personnes et face à emmanuel
mâcon qui va se retrouver de plus en
plus seul et je crois que la
discrimination des manuels macro envers
ces manifestants qui nous a fait du
petit stock tout cette semaine
finalement n'est pas enviable n'est pas
envisageable et cas le dernier une
situation de plus en plus compliqué à
mon avis on a un vide l on a entendu
beaucoup de restaurateurs
le propriétaire de magasin qui
s'interroge sur l'application la mise en
place concrète ne se passe
sanitaire c'est ça qui manifestement
leur pose problème est-ce que vous avez
des indications sur comment justement
appliquer ce fameux pass oui bien sûr on
nous a expliqué comment il disait se
passe avec une application août il faut
équiper notre personnel d'un téléphone
de rim tablettes
pour vérifier le passé ni terre le qr
code c'est assez rapide le seul point
c'est quand on a une seule entrée et
qu'on surveille les clientèles ça va
mais qu'on a une terrasse à l'extérieur
en plein air les gens se posent donc il
faut qu'on aille et les voir pour leur
expliquer pour que ça se passe bien donc
ça peut être très rapide
si le client se met à le pass sanitaire
élevé le monde font rapidement il n'y a
pas de souci à la mise en place mais
c'est vrai que le gouvernement a choisi
de faire porter le passé ni terre sur le
secteur privé le commerce tout ce qui
est loisirs et on doit malheureusement
si on veut pouvoir travailler
l'appliquer correctement si on veut
pouvoir essayer de continuer et sortir
de cette crise
je vous en prie on a vu dans les
manifestations des gens de tous bords en
clairement des vaccinés des non vaccinés
des personnes de tout âge mais certains
ont parlé de récupération politique
comment apprécier voire oui l'idée de la
récupération politique c'est toujours
pour délégitimer rappelez-vous les gilet
jaune reprap et bout la réforme des
retraites c'est toujours la même chose
finalement en anglais légitimation
permanence de mouvements oculaires moi
je crois que pendant qu'il est populaire
à ce mouvement
je pense que se sont énormément de
citoyens et très sincèrement c'est du
moins ce que j'ai vu dans les derniers
dans les manifestations donc je crois
que dire que c'est la récupération
politique très sincèrement c'est un
échappatoire qui n'a qui n'a aucun aucun
intérêt si ce n'est ne pas aborder livré
problème et se confronter vraiment de
dire notre démocratie et à notre avenir
donc heureusement la tuer parce que les
traitements le gouvernement aujourd'hui
n'est pas n'est pas ouverte aux abonnées
absentes par rapport à démocratie mais
ça on l'avait déjà un peu vu avec le
gilet jaune et avait la réforme des
retraites
ronan hallyday mon avis des
restaurateurs qui refuseront de
contrôler une passe d'autres qui
préfèrent tout simplement fermer
d'autres minoritaires mais en faveur ne
se passe est ce qu'au sens de votre
fédération
on parle d'une même voix c'est très
compliqué dans notre profession on a
aussi bien les hôteliers les
restaurateurs les traiteurs les gens qui
habitent dans des petits villages les
gens qui habitent dans des métropoles
des petits groupes des établissements de
famille et donc chacun et chacun est
amené un subit la crise de façon
différente
c'est sûr que pour les gros organismes
et ils ont le personnel et pour le
former pour le faire les petits ça peut
être rapide c'est tout ce qu'on nous on
conseille c'est bien sûr de suivre le
fait de scanner le pass sanitaires pour
être dans les règles parce que encore
une fois c'était comme de tout ce qu'on
nous a demandé on a fait auparavant
quitté le le caïd rappelle tout ce qui
était règles on l'a suivi et pour
pouvoir essayer de sortir de cette crise
ont été le bon élève on pourrait dire ça
comme ça en même temps parce que le
gouvernement avait mis des aides pour
nous pour nous accompagner faut pas
oublier qu'on a quand même des chiffres
d'affaires on a moins 60 disposions
d'hôtels fermé sur paris au mois d'août
c'est quelque chose d'incroyable paris
des sinistrés tout comme certaines
grandes métropoles
on n'en parle pas assez mais nous on
aura pas de saison estivale les grandes
villes et en septembre étape et
certainement des grandes manifestations
qui vont faire fuir tous qui touristique
donc c'est pas obligatoire mais ce match
qui est très agréable on nous
commerçants parce qu'on a besoin d'avoir
du monde pour travailler et pour ce
qu'on leur vie c'est de travailler de
faire le passé ni et oui c'est ont subi
le pacs unités encore une fois je sais
pas si c'est liberticide mais pas
rentrer dans ce débat là par contre tout
ce que je sais c'est que beaucoup de
pays le font on a new york qui en train
d'actuellement de réfléchir à un mètre
de passer ses restaurants c'est une
question qui est sur la table
moi tout ce que je veux c'est pouvoir
travailler sauver mon commerce pour
payer mes salariés et pourrait essayer
de survivre et d'avoir un établissement
soit pérenne et demain peut-être que
transmettre à mes enfants mais c'est
malheureusement on a on n'a pas le choix
et j'ai pas envie d'avoir battu
administratives pour défaut de passer ni
théo des choses comme ça
je me le sictom en pas avoir un conflit
avec un client qui n'a pas en face à
lithaire faut que tout le monde
comprenne
nous on n'a pas le choix je souhaitais
peut-être plus facile d'obliger le
vaccin soit été plus facile peut-être de
t'apporter se passer ni terre sur autre
chose que sur les loisirs
malheureusement on est là et on doit le
faire baisser accompagner la sortie de
crise nicolas vidal j'aimerais revenir
avec vous sur l'extension du face à
l'inter au sein même des hôpitaux
beaucoup de médecins l'ont énoncé quel
regard portez vous sur ce point là
précisément
ben c'est très inquiétant parce que ça
va être un refus effectivement de
soigner se passer car entrées des
hôpitaux d'ailleurs on va le dire il y
avait cette assemblée que ça c'est voter
ça c'est voter en deux fois voyez vous
ces deux tranches donc ça c'est voter
vers 10h et puis les vétérans qui est
pas content du vote des 222 ou 227 tu ne
me rappelle plus ça aussi c'est une
vraie question de fond la présence des
parlementaires à l'assemblée nationale
effectivement on a refait voter pour
accéder aux hôpitaux pour un pass à
litière ça c'est extrêmement grave
c'est extrêmement grave c'est absolument
liberticide et même sur pose un problème
d'égalité d'équité entre les citoyennes
d'accès aux soins d'accès aux soins
aussi de refus de soigner vous l'avez
dit plusieurs swan ans aujourd'hui le
dise concrètement dans les interviews
qui a un vrai problème là tu m'aimes
juridique à même pour eux juridique et
ça c'est terrible c'est comme d'ailleurs
la rupture de contrat de travail
notamment pour les cdi
ils ont enlevé le cdd le camp s'est
constitué dans les cd cdi pour se faire
vacciner si non vous ne savez ces
suspensions la rémunération et
suspension du contrat de travail et
après ce sera au bout du compte ça sera
quoi vous de moi ce sont des sentiments
donc ce bloc là des soins de l'accès aux
soins et se bloque la du travail lui
liberté de travailler c'est extrêmement
là je le dis c'est vraiment vous
liberticide et le concert constitué par
revenu là dessus il n'est pas revenu là
tu dont beaucoup aujourd'hui beaucoup de
questions à se poser et notamment les
français qui s'en posent énormément du
moins du moins ceux qui étaient dans la
rue aujourd'hui par centaines de
milliers nicolas vidal vous êtes
éditorialistes merci à vous romain vidal
vous êtes secrétaire général du
groupement national des indépendants de
l'hôtellerie
restauration à paris en ile de france
merci à vous deux messieurs même nom de
famille mais je répète pas de lien de
parenté merci à vous